Good afternoon, dear colleagues, dear
Vyacheslav Viktorovich, the so-called
collective West, led by the United States,
has been behaving
exceptionally aggressively towards Russia for
decades.  to say that this was succeeded to a certain
extent and the
war was unleashed and sanctions were introduced under
normal conditions, it would probably be difficult
to do this, but what they would like to
pay attention to, they should have
understood that they had already lost from the very beginning of
our special military operation,
because its beginning means  and the beginning of a
radical break in the break of the world order
in the American way,
this is the beginning of the transition from the liberal
globalist American
egocentrism to the truly
multipolar world of the West, which
has never declared such principles of
democracy as freedom of speech, pluralism,
respect and new opinion today
degenerates into a complete opposite
Is it possible that tourism turns on censorship the
closure of the media
arbitrariness against journalists today
we hear that they want to defeat us on the
battlefield,
what do you say, let them try, but
we do not refuse peace
negotiations buttons who refuses
should know that the further the more difficult
it is for them  will negotiate with us